allegiant stadium has been a hot topic
lately and last night while wwe's
summerslam was taking place reports have
downed concession stands blinding lights
and parking costs took center stage good
evening and thank you so much for
joining us tonight at midnight i'm sasha
loftis madison kimbrough is live from
the stadium with the latest on what some
are saying about this and to break down
the cause of these issues madison
i spoke to two people who attended last
night's event and while they were
pleased with summerslam it was the
cashless payment system outage that was
the talk of the night here at allegiant
stadium
some lights that surrounded
the ring at some point they had gotten
turned up to the point to where we
couldn't even really visibly see the
ring you know that's a disappointment
you know because i felt like we had
pretty good seats we were lower level
those that attended saturday night's wwe
summerslam 2021 got quite the show but
the main chatter was about the
concession stands being closed leaving
fans without food or water available
there was a group of employees standing
there and i said you know
do you guys have just a water cup my
father-in-law is diabetic and he said
no everything very rude everything's
shut down
everything's closed the fountains don't
work turns out the stadium's official
cashless payment system went down during
the wrestling match and it wasn't just
at allegiant stadium as there was an
outage nationwide it was resolved later
saturday night the company total system
services also known as tsys is a united
states credit card processor and they
have yet to comment on the matter but
another company called shift 4 payments
tweeted out that they are in close
contact with tsys to facilitate a
resolution as quickly as possible
meanwhile both attendees we spoke to
were frustrated but both agreed that
this wasn't an allegiant stadium issue
and it won't stop them from attending
upcoming events in the future even
though we had some issues this doesn't
really stop that we're not mad at you
know
anyone at allegiant stadium is just you
know our situation just wasn't the best
we reached out to allegiant stadium and
wwe for a comment on last night's issues
we have yet to hear back reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now